spider-man is returning to the Marvel
Universe and zendaya and Tom Holland are
pumped Sony and Marvel worked out a deal
to collaborate on a third spider-man
movie and Tom showed his excitement over
the news by posting this clip of
Leonardo DiCaprio in the wolf of
wallstreet to Instagram
[Applause]
the Xolos dog meanwhile Tom's co-star
zendaya took to Twitter on Friday to do
a little celebrating of her own posting
this little gif of a dancing spider-man
always loved when Sony and Disney
initially failed to strike a new deal
that would keep the beloved webslinger
in the MCU Tom stayed mum on the issue
but when he took the stage to promote
his upcoming Pixar flick onward at d23
he seemingly addressed the elephant in
the room telling the crowd it's been a
crazy week but I want to let you know
I'm grateful from the bottom of my heart
then he quoted Tony Stark's iconic line
from Avengers endgame I love you 3000 et
caught up with Tom's far from home
co-star John Favreau at the same
convention and he had this to say about
the future of the franchise the Spidey
debacle what do you make of it what
happens to happy in May now what happens
to happy omit well I guess happy single
again after all that time took 10 years
for him to get into a good relationship
you know it's still early days and I'm
as a fan I'm cautiously hopeful that
something will come together because I
think all the fans want to see those
characters together I don't mean happy
in May I mean I mean Spidey with with
the MCU so you know it's still early
days and things you know you don't know
is what you read isn't always indicative
of where things are right now so I
hopefully I'll find out more while I'm
here but uh but as a fan I'm hopeful
that you know cautiously optimistic
holding out hope that this isn't the
final chapter of that story
[Applause]
[Music]